much like the legendary men in black the  scp foundation works hard to keep the  strange and supernatural under wraps  this involves a lot of making people  forget about the horrifying things  they've seen which they're able to do  thanks to chemicals known as amnesics  these are drugs that cause selective  memory loss but where do these chemicals  come from the dark secret behind  amnesics production exists in the deep  deep ocean the chemicals are derived  from a giant eel known as scp-3000 or  anantashia it's a creature so immense in  size when discovered by people in the  past it's been treated as a kind of god  and this god likes human sacrifices as a  whole bunch of disappeared divers can  attest to scp-3000 is all too happy to  devour people who get too close and when  it does it secretes a chemical that  causes memory loss and disorientation  through refining this chemical the scp  foundation was able to create the  amnestics they so often use today